liebe hörerinnen und hörer ich begrüße
sie und euch sehr herzlich zur folge
190 des faz einspruch podcast heute am
dezember 20 21 unsere vorletzte folge in
diesem jahr volle zufolge vor
weihnachten mein name ist helene
bobrowski politik korrespondentin in der
berliner redaktion der faz und bei mir
hier ist wieder pia lorenz mann aus köln
ich bin freier journalistinnen und
juristinnen also vier wir haben ein
ziemlich volles paket mal wieder wobei
ja jetzt erst gerade heute kannst du
stolz eine regierungserklärung abgibt
und sage ich mal der politische betrieb
ja erst so richtig in gang kommt in
berlin haben wir trotzdem ein bisschen
was zu corona genau ein relativ kurzes
corona update und dann hast du
gesprochen mit sebastian fiedler seines
zeichens nicht nur spd politiker und
jetzt mitglied des bundestags sondern
auch ein kriminal hauptkommissar damals
der vorsitzende des bundes deutscher
kriminalbeamter genau und wir sprechen
auch im weiteren sinne über corona also
über die sogenannte querdenker szene
inwiefern die sich eigentlich
radikalisieren was die justiz tun kann
und insbesondere was man tun kann gegen
die radikalisierung auf telegramm wo es
ja jetzt auch mord aufrufe und ähnliches
gab dann haben wir ein bgh-urteil zur
telemedizin auch im aller weitesten
sinne genau wir haben zweimal die
digitalisierung einmal in der medizin
und einmal im rechtswesen und wer hätte
das gedacht dass deutsche rechtswesen
gadget wahnsinn dass wir das noch
erleben dürfen so zu sagen dann haben
wir einen fall eines referendars der
mitglied der rechtsextremen partei
dritter weg ist und die frage ist darf
er referendar sein oder nicht
außerdem was neues zum bea das jetzt
kommt und natürlich das gerechte urteil
[Musik]
so dann fangen wir an pia kleiner
nachtrag zu unserem
corona update genau wie immer gibt es
ein wöchentliches corona update von uns
und wir fangen an mit den wichtigsten
dingen vorab karneval fällt aus der ist
dann war im rheinland ein großes
gestohlen zu hören es wird kein karneval
in den räumen geben 2022 keine sitzung
keine karnevalspartys drin der
straßenkarneval ist noch offen das
rheinland ist zutiefst deprimiert
ansonsten sollen gemusterte da gibt es
jetzt eine einigung der
gesundheitsministerinnen von bund und
ländern in zukunft auch wenn zweig plus
gilt also man geimpft und genesen und
getestet sein muss trotz des plus keinen
test vorlegen müssen die motivation
dahinter ist irgendwie klar es geht
darum dass mehr leute sich boostern
lassen sollen da kann man gleich in
zweifacher hinsicht meines erachtens
fragen wie sinnvoll das ist denn
gleichzeitig wurde klar dass vermutlich
ab januar oder februar wieder ein
engpass geben wird in sachen impfstoff
man kann sich vielleicht auch fragen
irgendwie sinnvoll das ist jetzt so eine
lockerung zu machen für gepostete wenn
gleichzeitig eigentlich schon klar ist
dass die um die grundvariante und
spätestens im januar erreichen wird also
in die eu kommission hat heute gesagt
mitte januar werden wird die omikron
variante die dominierende in deutschland
seien genau und da eigentlich schon klar
ist dass da der auch der booster schutz
immer noch nicht ausreichend ist oder
jedenfalls weit schwächer als bei den
anderen varianten kann man sich
vielleicht schon fragen ob das jetzt
irgendwie sinn ergibt das jetzt für
wahrscheinlich drei wochen mal so zu
regnen und da muss man es wieder
aufheben aber es soll jetzt wohl erst
mal so sein und ich gehe davon aus dass
wollte ich euch natürlich auch nicht
vorenthalten dass es dafür wieder eine
änderung einer verordnung geben wird von
der ich der ich mich jetzt schon relativ
lange mit corona maßnahmen beschäftige
in dieser woche zum ersten mal gehört
habe nämlich die sogenannte cupid 19
schutzmaßnahmen ausnahmen verordnung die
heißt echt so das ist kein witz das ist
eine rechtsverordnung der
bundesregierung die dazu dient
erleichterungen und ausnahmen von corona
geboten und verboten für geimpfte
genießen und getestete zu regeln und
diese verordnung wurde mit wirkung zum
anfang der woche zum ersten mal geändert
es wurde nämlich klar gestellt dass es
künftig auch für geimpfte und genießen
wieder kontakt beschränkungen geben kann
im privaten bereich und auch dieser
grundsatz der jetzt ich glaube fast ein
jahr lang dann im prinzip galt seit dem
letzten winter das nämlich geimpfte und
genesen bei der anzahl zusammentreffen
der personen nicht mitgezählt werden der
geht ab jetzt nicht mehr oder zumindest
nicht mehr zwingend und es ist auch
nicht rein akademisch interessant
sondern es haben auch schon mehrere
länder davon gebrauch gemacht also in
berlin und auch hier in nordrhein
westfalen haben jetzt auch schon sind
jetzt auch schon zweig veranstaltungen
also nur für gäste und genießen eine
geöffnete veranstaltungen in
geschlossenen räumen auf maximal 50
personen begrenzt sachsen hat es glaube
ich schon sogar auf nur 20 personen
trotz zweig begrenzt vermutlich wird
also diese hübsche verordnung von der
ihr damit dann jetzt auch mal gehört
habe dann womöglich jetzt noch geändert
um eine differenzierung zwischen
geimpften und geposteten vorzunehmen ja
in der tat ist es ganz schön schwer da
immer mit zu kommen auf dem laufenden zu
sein nicht nur für die armen gastwirte
die sich dann immer wieder auf schöne
neue regeln einstellen müssen ja und
sondern auch für die normalbürger wir
versuchen ein bisschen jede woche ein
bisschen ordnung in dieses chaos zu
bringen
so und jetzt begrüßen wir ganz herzlich
bei uns sebastian fiedler den wir gerade
schon vorgestellt haben er ist seit
september
bundestagsabgeordnete der spd hat aber
auch ein langes vorleben als
kriminalhauptkommissar und außerdem
gewerkschafter im bund der deutschen
kriminalbeamten herzlich willkommen herr
fiedler
wir haben vor zwei tagen gehört vom
bundesinnenministerium die einschätzung
dass viele der sogenannten querdenker
also der ja aller derjenigen die man die
sich gegen die korona maßnahmen und nun
auch gegen impfen wären das die immer
radikaler würden so sehen es auch einige
landesämter für verfassungsschutz wir
haben gesehen den fackel aufmarsch vor
dem haus der sächsischen
gesundheitsministerin köpping und andere
mord aufrufe gegen politiker auf
telegramm wie schätzen sie die szene ein
monster sorgen machen vor
radikalisierung
weiterer radikalisierung würde ich sagen
ich wurde gerade ich wollte es gehört
auch ergänzen also ich würde auch sagen
die hacker schon stattgefunden und ich
versuche immer den harten kern dieser
szene nicht so sehr mit dem begriff
querdenker zu belegen weil der zumindest
in der vergangenheit man positiv
besetzter begriff ist sondern endet die
verschwörungs extremisten auch wenn das
vielleicht ein bisschen sperrig daher
kommt aber greift ist das doch
vielleicht auch weil ich auch wahrnehmen
das ist sozusagen sondern mischung ist
derjenigen die wir dem harten
rechtsextreme milieu zuzuordnen dann
reiße bürger sehen und andere coole
rechte
ideologien dann wird aber eben auch
leute dabei die sich zunehmend
radikalisieren die wir so typischerweise
der bürgerlichen gesellschaftlichen
mitte zu ordern würden und das hat ein
stück was natürlich damit zu tun dass
die rechtsextremen hier ein nährboden
für sich entdeckt haben und den nutzen
und versuchen den entsprechend zu
befeuern man könnte also sagen öl ins
feuer zu gießen an der stelle wo es
sowieso schon was los
wir haben die extremisten die sowieso
schon gibt die dieses neue thema jetzt
für sich nutzen auch zur mobilisierung
und da vor allem auf verunsicherte
menschen
[Musik]
zu sich rüber ziehen wollen oder wie
würden sie das sagen also diese was so
typischerweise ein phänomen das man
gemeinhin als entgrenzung des
rechtsextremismus bezeichnet
ja weil die kollision ist ja ein prozess
das ist ja kein punktuelles ereignis und
insoweit ist es sozusagen natürlich das
interesse der
extremen das will ich ganz allgemein
formulieren für alle extremisten sie in
ein entsprechendes kommunikations milieu
hinein zu ziehen und das sind in
unterschiedliche plattformen die
nachrichtendienste sprechen da immer
richtigerweise so von echo kammern
bezogen auch soziale netzwerke aber hier
sticht eben jetzt in diesem umfeld doch
tatsächlich ganz besonders stark heraus
dieser dienst telegramm der eben im
prinzip so zweigleisig zu betrachten ist
auf der einen seite ist der messenger
dienst
wir haben auch die beiden könnten uns
damit nachricht zu schicken und auf der
anderen seite ist eröffnet die plattform
und versucht nach wie vor durch alle
rechtlichen raster hindurch zu fahren
jedenfalls hält sich nicht an die
regularien die wir eigentlich geplant
worden so vorgesehen haben und das ist
glaube ich eine entscheidendes moment um
das muss man glaube ich deswegen
herausgreifen weil nach unserer
einschätzung eigentlich die
radikalisierung gerade da besonders
passiert in abgrenzung zu allen
öffentlichen medien also man könnte auch
sagen zu ihrem beruf statt
ja wir lassen uns mal über telegramm
sprechen das ist ja derzeit auch stark
im politischen gespräch nachdem es die
von mir jetzt schon gerade benannten
mord aufrufe gab auch gegen den
sächsischen ministerpräsidenten dafür ja
immer der begriff telegramm auch bei der
in idar oberstein wo der junge
tankstellen mitarbeiter ermordet wurde
gab es hinterher starke reaktionen
darauf telegramm also dieser ehemals
messenger dienst der aber auch
tatsächlich die frau die funktion einer
plattform mittlerweile hat weil es da
gruppen chats gibt in der bis zu 100000
oder mehr drin sein können
ist also in der kritik und die frage ist
was man da tun kann fangen wir
vielleicht mal vorne an
warum ist eigentlich telegramm bei
rechtsextremisten und bei allen
denjenigen sie haben es ja beschrieben
diesen ganzen durchaus heterogen milieu
der korona
maßnahmen gegner so beliebt
das kann man ganz einfach beantworten
weil er de facto bisher unreguliert ist
und weil man sich dort völlig normal
sagen nahezu völlig straffrei
austoben kann zumindest ist das so die
idee die sich dort aus zogen also es
wird eben nicht in einem maße wie das
sonst wünschenswert und gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben ist dass bei facebook und
twitter und co eigentlich so passieren
sollte entsprechend entsprechende
inhalte gelöscht die meldewege die
eigentlich vorgeschrieben sind werden
nicht eingehalten coco zu mit den
sicherheitsbehörden würde man sich
anders wünschen also lange rede kurzer
sinn im unterschied zu facebook und co
ist es leidlich unreguliert die
betreiber sitzen sie mit ihrem team in
dubai und dem für sich in anspruch sich
nicht an die gesetzlichen
rahmenbedingungen halten zu müssen und
deswegen das ist der grund dafür warum
darüber diskutieren müssen ob wir uns
die zeit erlauben können entsprechenden
gerichtlichen verfahren das auszufechten
oder besagen müssen wir müssen doch an
der einen oder anderen stelle gesetzlich
noch mal klar
nun hat ja die bundesregierung ihre
einschätzung kund getan jetzt gerade
nochmal gestern in der
regierungspressekonferenz
das telegramm klar unter das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz fällt das ja die
von ihnen beschriebene regulierung
vorsieht also etwa die verpflichtung
strafbare inhalte zu löschen ab februar
dann auch dem bundeskriminalamt zu
melden aus dem grund dass eben telegramm
nicht nur ein messenger dienst ist
sondern eben auch diese andere funktion
hat jetzt ist es aber so dass es ja
nicht viel hilft wenn jetzt die
deutschen behörden sagen wir sehen das
so wenn telegramm einfach nicht auf
die anfrage deutscher behörden reagiert
und sich da einfach stumm stellt und so
tut als ob ihnen das alles also aus als
ob diesen dienst und seine manager das
einfach überhaupt nicht zu interessieren
hat
genau deswegen steht nur es ist das was
ich gerade andeutete deswegen wird man
das dann fackellicht entsprechend
ausstatten dass es gibt ja noch zwei
aktuelle
bußgeldverfahren die nach meinem
kenntnisstand noch immer laufen die sich
detailregelungen ranken weil die
einschätzung wie sie gerade geschildert
haben ja auch die alte bundesregierung
schon so hatte das
bundesjustizministerium als christine
lambrecht es noch leitet die selbe
einschätzung davon und hatte
entsprechend den bußgeldverfahren
initiiert ich habe das nur deswegen
versucht die diskussion etwas zu
erweitern weil es natürlich auch so ein
bisschen die zeitschiene mit in die
diskussion hinein wird das ist schon
relevant und deswegen ist der vorstoß
sind unter anderem boris pistorius
gemacht hat natürlich ein durchaus
wichtiger politischer vorstoß in dem er
sich an diejenigen gewandt hat wie apple
und google liegen überhaupt ermöglichen
dass diese applikationen bereitgestellt
werden und ab jetzt sozusagen an deren
compliance richtlinien die eigentlich
diese aktivitäten ausschließen würden
dass es durchaus noch mal ein
zusätzlicher hebel der
politisch wird und der möglicherweise
auch schneller zum erfolg führen könnte
man es im ergebnis bedeuten würde dass
sie auf ihrem smartphone schlichter
geraten die applikation gar nicht mehr
runter laden sollen solange sich
telegramm nicht an recht und gesetz hält
genau irgendwie vielleicht doch die von
ihnen angesprochenen bußgeldverfahren
das für die hörerinnen und hörer noch
mal zu sagen da gibt es diese zwei
bußgeldverfahren die beine ich schon im
april ja angestoßen wurden und derzeit
ist es aber noch nicht einmal gelungen
diese anhörungsschreiben an
telegramm zuzustellen die eben sie
sagten in dubai sitzen und das ist jetzt
über das auswärtige amt über die
deutsche botschaft an das dortige
außenministerium übergeben worden aber
was seitdem passiert ist wissen wir
schlicht nicht also man kann
konzertieren dass der respekt den
telegramm vor deutschen behörden hat
nicht wahnsinnig groß ist um es mal
vorsichtig auszudrücken das heißt jetzt
ist die diskussion muss man vielleicht
zu anderen mitteln greifen druck ausüben
vielleicht auch wirtschaftlichen druck
oder com boris pistorius der
niedersächsische innenminister ins spiel
der eben sagt naja wenn wir jetzt am
anfang google und apple zu sagen ihr
dürft das einfach schlicht nicht mehr
auf ihren geräten zu lassen dann könnte
sich telegramm vielleicht bewegen da ist
aber in deutschland natürlich sofort zu
erwarten dass und so ist es ja auch
schon geschehen die netzgemeinde empört
auf schreibt das sind doch die mittel
einer diktatur du bist kommst auch einen
punktsieg und eine spontane reaktion zu
liefern das ist ja quatsch weil ist
jeder letztlich darum das war ja teil
unsere unserer diskussion jetzt die wir
gerade hatten das deutsches recht und
gesetz umgesetzt werden sollen dass wir
festgestellt haben dass ich jetzt hier
ein akteur im markt nicht daran hält
also wir würden eine solche diskussionen
in anderen marktsegmenten der wirtschaft
ja auch nicht zulassen und tolerieren
dass sich jemand einfach nicht an die
regularien hält sondern sich sozusagen
ins ausland davon spielt und dann für
sich beansprucht sonderregelung in
anspruch nehmen zu können also insoweit
halte ich das für nicht nur legitim
sondern nahezu geboten so schnell wie
möglich maßnahmen zu ergreifen denn
vielleicht auch noch einmal die wirkung
in den mittelpunkt stellen hier geht es
jetzt nicht nur das ja schon schlimm
genug darum dass sie sich ein ein
vielleicht neuer extremistische
terminologie kern weiter etabliert und
herausstellt
staatsfeindlicher kern der nach meiner
festen überzeugung auch nach einer
pandemie uns noch erhalten bleiben wird
sondern jetzt in der pandemie hat er
zusätzlich natürlich die wirkung dass
hier leib und leben von vielen menschen
in deutschland dadurch gefährdet wird
dass diese falsch erzählung fake news
ins geschichten und so weiter diese
kunden erzählungen der weiter raum
greifen und dadurch tatsächlich eine
gefahr für die einzelnen die daran
glauben sich möglicherweise deswegen
wegen falscher informationen nicht
impfen lassen und sondern essen nimmt
sozusagen die ganze gesellschaft in
geiselhaft
belastet unsere intensivstation das muss
man mal auf den punkt bringen und das
alles funktioniert gerade deswegen so
gut aus sicht dieser extremistischen
bestrebungen weil sie diese plattform
haben deswegen es ist durchaus ein
zeitliches momentum was wir auch nutzen
müssen und deswegen kann ich nur alle
unterstützen die zusätzlichen druck auf
diese plattform ausüben um das zu
beenden jetzt hat aber konstantin von
notz das ist der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der grünen und ihr
koalitionspartner in der ampel regierung
selbst gestern getwittert naja dass
diese diskussion um verbote oder
beschränkungen von von teleplan bringen
überhaupt nichts schließlich würden die
leute ja sofort auf andere plattformen
ausweichen was sagen sie dazu
hatte er auch einen alternativvorschlag
gebracht nein denn den hatte ich auch
vermisst also jetzt das ist natürlich
das ist einerseits natürlich nicht ganz
falsch hilft uns also diese betrachtung
hilft uns nur an der stelle dich weiter
die packung ist es jetzt gerade so dass
wir feststellen dass dieser teile
radikalisierung exakt auf dieser
plattform in großem ausmaß stattfindet
und ich glaube
es geht ich kenne keine plattform die in
vergleichbarem ausmass eine solche
bedeutung für diese szene hat mit tele
werden was muss man einfach feststellen
dass ist die lage der dinge gerade und
eine andere gibt es derzeit nicht die
das jetzt auch nicht so wenn das so wäre
dann haben wir eine neue lage dann
müssen wir es neu bewerten und dann
müssen wir uns mit einer weiteren
plattform auseinandersetzen die kenne
ich derzeit nicht was er vielleicht
andeutet das ist durchaus richtig dass
wir in anderen extremistischen bereichen
wissen dass sich andere resonanz räume
echo kammern wie sie das auch immer
nennen wollen natürlich finden wir
finden mit anderen extremistischen
bereich gaming plattformen
spieleplattformen zum beispiel die eine
besondere bedeutung haben also das ist
schon durchaus richtig aber eine so
schnelle ausweichbewegung jetzt gerade
in dieser welle die dafür fehlt mir die
fantasie dass das so schnell wie möglich
wäre ich glaube die wirkung wenn mit
telegramm hier enger in angriff nehmen
würden wäre überaus groß und würde uns
alle wirklich helfen na ja und wenn ein
verein verboten wird besteht natürlich
auch immer die gefahr dass sich eine
nachfolgeorganisation mit denselben
leuten irgendwie formte das ist ja aber
auch da kein argument dagegen wenn die
voraussetzungen für ein verbot vorliegen
dass es verboten wird gut kommen wir
vielleicht noch mal zu einem letzten
punkt meinen sie denn dass das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz in seiner jetzigen
form überhaupt
ausreichend ist um sage ich mal dafür zu
sorgen dass soja das ziel im netz
dieselben regeln gelten wie in der
analogen welt oder muss da noch
nachgebessert werden
ich würde jetzt nicht stand heute eine
direkte nachbesserung fordern wollen ich
würde uns noch alle ermutigen die
diskussion nicht zu beenden wenn jetzt
am ersten februar neuer regularien
gelten weil ich glaube wir müssen schon
dauerhaft im blick haben welche
beantwortung welche sorgfaltspflichten
solche netzbetreiber denn eigentlich
treffen also inwieweit müssen sie selbst
aktiv werden um solche entweder
inkriminierte inhalte oder fake news
tatsächlich zu identifizieren wie gut
sind sie da in ihrer compliance welcher
teil ist da rechtlich vorgeschrieben im
unterschied vielleicht zu anderen
wirtschaftsbereichen
erinnere an die geldwäsche diskussion
wenn sie ein konto bei der bank haben
dann ist es völlig normal dass die bank
alle transaktionen monitor und
verdächtige transaktionen dann
anschließend melden muss so etwas
vergleichbares haben wir im bereich der
plattform derzeit noch nicht deswegen
wie ich schon dass die diskussion hier
noch nicht an einem ende angekommen ist
sondern dass wir sie glaube ich
fortschreitend noch weiterführen auf
europäischer ebene gibt es ja die
pflicht nach kinderpornografischen
inhalten
selbst zu suchen also wirklich für die
plattform also ihre ihre inhalte
daraufhin zu scannen das heißt da würden
sie sagen muss man zumindest mal darüber
sprechen ob auch das auf
hass und hetze oder sonstige strafbare
inhalte auszuweiten wäre er 100
prozentig und ich würde das vielleicht
auch ganz abstrakt einmal formulieren
wollen ist doch völlig klar wenn wir in
einer solchen industriellen revolution
wie der digitalisierung und der
fortschreitenden digitalisierung uns
befinden dann müssen wir ja nicht nur in
den blick nehmen welchen
gesellschaftlichen technologischen
fortschritt das bedeutet sondern wir
müssen natürlich immer auch die
schattenseiten die so etwas mitbringen
kann mit bedenken und müssen dann
überlegen wie kann der staat
organisieren wie kann die wirtschaft
organisieren das möglichst compliance
auf eingehalten wird das recht und
gesetz ethische vorgaben auch
eingehalten werden durch die
plattformbetreiber und da würden wir
natürlich nicht zulassen dass unsere
wert und gesetzes maßstäbe dann
möglicherweise dadurch kontaminiert
werden nur das weil der betreiber dann
im ausland sitzt also einsitz nimmt
deswegen glaube ich werden das alles
also sowohl die sogenannte
kinderpornografie als auch hass und
hetze und andere extremistische
bestrebungen immer weiter teil der
debatte sein müssen weil sie im prinzip
eng verbunden sind mit dem fortschreiten
der digitalisierung und das müssen wir
gesellschaftlich demokratisch und
parlamentarisch aushandeln ja ein
schönes schlusswort herr fiedler vielen
dank wir werden die debatte weiter im
auge behalten mal sehen was ich tue top
telegramm eines tages doch noch das
anhörungsschreiben
beantwortet oder wie es weitergeht und
auch natürlich wie die netzgemeinde
reagiert denn wenn man wenn man sich
anschaut was in den letzten jahren
gewesen ist auch im zusammenhang mit dem
urhebergesetz sind sie ja schon nicht
nur sehr lautstark sondern teils auch
einflussreich insofern werden wir da
weiter im gespräch bleiben würde ich
sagen vielen dank für heute danke ihnen
es geht weiter in unserer schönen
kategorie was war mit einem urteil des
bundesgerichtshofs aus der letzten woche
zum thema telemedizin
der bgh hat entschieden dass
krankenkassen nicht pauschal diagnose
therapie empfehlung und krankschreibung
per app bewerben dürfen und zwar weder
nach der alten noch noch doch der neun
und damit aktuell geltenden fassung des
heilmittelwerbegesetz hwg
im hwg gibt es eine vorschrift die
werbung für unzulässig erklärt für die
erkennung oder behandlung von
krankheiten die ich zitiere nicht auf
eigener wahrnehmung an dem zu
behandelnden menschen oder tier beruht
also es geht auf deutsch gesagt um um
video
arztkonsultationen sozusagen seit 2009
10 gibt es einen satz zwei dieser
vorschrift der es erlaubt solche fern
behandlungen also online behandlungen
zu bewerben die unter verwendung von
kommunikationsmedien stattfinden wenn
nach allgemein anerkannten fachlichen
standards ein persönlicher ärztlicher
kontakt mit dem zu behandelnden menschen
nicht erforderlich ist bisher klar warum
das eingefügt wurde die telemedizin
sollte gestärkt werden es gibt ja
bekanntlich vor allem in der fläche also
auf dem land immer weniger abständen und
ärzte da ist natürlich relativ sinnlos
zwei stunden irgendwie zu einer erst
hinzufahren wenn man einen hautausschlag
hat oder so also muss man das nutzen
sind in zeiten von corona natürlich ein
schlechtes beispiel weil man da trotzdem
noch eine diagnose bekommen kann die
sich eben nicht mal irgendwie per video
machen lässt aber wenn man zum beispiel
hautausschlag hat dann noch das ja
eigentlich schon sein dass man sich
dafür nicht drei stunden ins auto setzen
muss
der sachverhalt der jetzt vom bgh
entschieden wurde war eine private
krankenversicherung nach eigenen angeben
angaben die erste komplett digitale
krankenvollversicherung deutschlands die
herz seit november 217 digitale
arztbesuche angeboten über eine
smartphone-app und über diese app
konnten sich dann die versicherten
dieser krankenversicherung mit ärzten in
der schweiz kurzschließen das heißt die
konten von denen sich einfach online per
video diagnostizieren und behandeln
lassen denn in der schweiz ist es seit
jahren erlaubt dass ärztinnen und ärzte
patienten digital behandeln gegen diese
werbung der privaten krankenversicherung
hat geklagt die zentrale zur bekämpfung
unlauteren wettbewerbs
logisch denn es geht um werbung kleiner
ausflug für die jura nord diese
vorschrift aus dem hwg ist eine markt
verhaltens regelung im sinne von § 3a
des gesetzes gegen den unlauteren
wettbewerbs laut bgh muss also die
krankenversicherung diese werbung nach §
8 uwg unterlassen so
ist erst mal klar wer sich per app
behandeln lässt also per video
sprechstunde untersuchen lässt in
anführungszeichen den kann natürlich die
ärztin oder der arzt nicht irgendwie
abtasten oder abklopfen oder abhören ist
also logisch dass erstmal das unter
diese norm im hwg fällt weil der arzt
sich eben keine eigene wahrnehmung im
sinne dieser normen bilden kann jetzt
konnte man sich aber schon fragen ist
das denn nicht nach satz 2 zulässig also
wenn nach allgemein anerkannten
fachlichen standards ein persönlicher
ärztlicher kontakt nicht nötig ist der
bgh jetzt klargestellt und das ist schon
eine wichtige entscheidung deshalb haben
wir die auch aufgenommen dass solche
allgemein anerkannten fachlichen
standards nicht das berufsrecht der
ärzte sind also die nette idee war ja
eigentlich wir umgehen dieses verbot
hier in deutschland indem wir einfach
sagen den deutschen patientinnen und
patienten sagen ihr könnt ja die ärztin
in der schweiz
kontaktieren das heißt das sind ja ärzte
die schweizerische und berufsrecht
unterliegen und die dürfen ja digitaler
behandlungen durchführen netter versuch
der bgh findiger trick wahrscheinlich
von den juristen und juristinnen der
privaten krankenversicherung ersonnen
hat aber nicht weitergeholfen denn eben
es geht nicht um das berufsrecht der
behandelnden ärzte sondern es geht laut
dem bgh darum dass diese allgemein
anerkannten fachlichen standards die
nach deutschem recht sein müssen konkret
nach 6 30 absatz 6 30 a bgb tschuldigung
der regel die pflichten bei
medizinischen behandlungsvertrag und das
wird dann immer konkretisiert durch
leitlinien es gibt leitlinien
medizinischer fachgesellschaften und es
gibt die richtlinien des gemeinsamen
bundesausschusses die sozusagen vorgaben
machen dann für die medizinerinnen und
mediziner in deutschland und hier hatte
diese private krankenversicherung ja so
ein umfassendes angebot gemacht und hat
gesagt womit auch immer was auch immer
ihr problem ist sie können auf jeden
fall sich digital irgendwie
diagnostizieren und behandeln lassen und
sich dabei gerade nicht auf bestimmte
krankheiten und beschwerden beschränkt
die man halt per video untersuchung easy
erkennen könnte hautausschlag oder so
und dass das also dass ärztinnen und
ärzte alles digital behandeln dürfen in
irgendwelchen deutschen leitungen der
medizinischer fachgesellschaften oder
sowas zulässig wäre das hatte nicht mal
die beklagte krankenversicherung
behauptet und das ist ganz offenbar auch
nicht so und hat der bgh gesagt das ist
maßgeblich es geht hier nicht darum was
die was die behandelnden ärzte in der
schweiz dürfen es wäre also auf jeden
fall denkbar gewesen dafür zu werben
dass man zum beispiel ein hautausschlag
irgendwie sich diagnostizieren lassen
kann per app und solche online video
sprechstunden die bieten ja auch
zahlreiche ärztinnen und ärzte in
deutschland längst an und der bgh hat
das sollte man vielleicht auch noch mal
klar stellen wir das ganze letzte woche
auch so ein bisschen durcheinander ging
in den medien hat solche online
sprechstunde nicht verboten hat auch
nicht die werbung dafür verboten sondern
der bgh hat jetzt eigentlich nur gesagt
dass man nicht damit werden darf dass
man einfach alles in zukunft jede
krankheit per online video sprechstunde
irgendwie lösen könne deswegen sagte ich
dass das ist das erste digitalisierungs
thema das wir heute in der sendung haben
das klingt auf den ersten blick so ein
bisschen schließlich und rückständig
aber auf der anderen seite muss man ja
auch durchaus mal sagen es ist schon
nachvollziehbar dass man eben nicht jede
krankheit per video diagnostizieren oder
sogar behandeln kann sondern es auch in
zukunft aber bleiben soll das natürlich
der persönliche kontakt zwischen der
ärztin und dem patient der idealfall
bleibt vielleicht auch der standard
bleibt sei der inhalt es geht um so ganz
klar visuell und akustisch erkennbar so
einschätzbaren beschwerden erzählte
neulich eine landärztin mit der ich
sprach dass gerade im november dezember
ein beträchtlicher teil ihrer patienten
tatsächlich
vor allem kommen weil sie diese
gespräche mit der ärztin führen wollen
und wir sehen natürlich irgend also ich
meine das jetzt auch gar nicht wenn ich
gar nicht darüber lustig machen im
gegenteil das ist halt da drückt dann
der schuh und es fehlt an einem
gesprächspartner und das kann natürlich
durchaus auch sehr heilsam sein ich
glaube dem einen oder anderen arzt wer
ist ganz froh ist diese menschen
irgendjemanden anders finden wenn sie
dann so gutherzig sind wie die frau die
ich kenne dann legen sie dann diese
termine immer an das ende ihrer
sprechstunde weil dann quasi oben nennt
zeit ist und mit denen zu reden das wird
natürlich nach der geo dafür bekommt man
nicht so wahnsinnig viel geld also ja
alles nichts die helene jetzt hier so
kompetent zitiert
kurzweilig in diesem bereich selber
nicht so wahnsinnig fit bin nur zu
merken jetzt nach diesem jahr etwas
komplizierten urteil also habe ich es
richtig verstanden
telemedizin ist in deutschland in
überhaupt nicht prinzipiell verboten
sondern da gab es vor einigen jahren
meine lockerung dass man sagen
diejenigen behandlungen die dafür
geeignet sind also sprich hautausschlag
oder anderes wo man nicht abhören oder
sonst was muss die die darf ein arzt
auch per app anbieten das bezahlt dann
auch die krankenkasse und das läuft
alles ganz normal und dafür darf ich
dann auch werben ich darf aber nicht
werben wenn ich irgendwie das komplette
paket anbietet das in deutschland eben
gar nicht über telemedizin angeboten
werden darf ja so kann man es
zusammenfassen das ist so etwas
kompliziert also die frage ist dann noch
so ein bisschen soll dieses werbeverbot
eigentlich sie auch wirklich
durchschlagen dann auf das verbot das
die ärztlich behandeln dürfen und so
aber im prinzip ist es genauso ich darf
diese behandlung durchführen als arzt
also bei krankheiten die ich erkennen
kann im rahmen einer video untersuchung
und dann darf ich natürlich auch dafür
werben
ich wollte aber gerade mal fragen wir ja
auch bei anwälten die werbung generell
verboten ist nah an werte dürfen ja für
ihr da gab es auch die all diese
lustigen fälle von anwälten die
irgendwie
auf ihre kaffeebecher und auf golfbälle
und ich weiß nicht was alles aufgehoben
ihren namen gedruckt haben geworben
haben ja das ist bei ärzten ich dachte
ehrlich gesagt auch dass das für andere
freie berufe auch bild und auch für es
geht um die werbung der der ärztin ärzte
selbst sondern es geht darum werbung von
krankenkassen regelt dass krankenkassen
die die verbale guten ok ärzte dürfen
nämlich auch nicht werben oder nein
zumindest auch nur in sehr begrenzten
sehr begrenzt okay dann haben wir auch
das klargestellt also da gab es gibt
keine lockerung
sondern es geht um krankenkassen dürfen
natürlich werben und tun das ja auch in
hohem maße
und damit kommen wir zu einem ganz
anderen thema dass du dir an geschaut
hast elena in sachsen ist etwas passiert
ein vorbestrafter aktivist der rechten
splitterpartei also kleinstpartei der
dritte weg darf referendar werden das
ist erst mal lange aber
selbstverständlich denn mehrere andere
gerichte in anderen bundesländern wo der
herr sich zuvor schon beworben hatte
haben das abgelehnt da kann man sich ja
jetzt schon etwas wundern ich erinnerte
mich selbst an meinen beginn als
referendaren am kammergericht hier in
berlin wo wir uns alle versammelt haben
und von dem ich glaube kammergerichts
präsidenten das wichtigste gesagt bekam
und dann war ein anderer ausbilder da
der uns dann so etwas erklärt wie das am
gericht alles so läuft für die
referendare und an den anderen stationen
und härtet den schönen satz gesagt naja
der referendar ist ja so etwas wie der
vormarsch des gerichts habe ich nie
vergessen er sagte als ich hoffe ihnen
darüber waren schon revanche und keine
beamten mehr wie früher sagte
angestellt im öffentlichen dienst und
dann ist es also bei ihnen würde wird
alles was also das öffentliche
dienstrecht das schlechteste aus dem
öffentlichen dienstrecht und das
schlechtes aus dem beamtenrecht
zusammengetan und das ohne dass der
ganze schon das ganze noch zum miesesten
gehalt aller zeiten gerade zeiten mit
gar nicht so wenig arbeit also da hat
man dann richtig lust unser kläger in
unserem fall hatte auch offenbar richtig
lust aufs referendariat vielleicht
erzählen wir erst mal kurz etwas über
seine person um das ganze einzuordnen
wie du schon gesagt das bier er ist
mitglied der rechtsextremen
kleinstpartei dritter weg die vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird aber
nicht verboten ist dritter weg übrigens
wer sich gefragt warum die eigentlich so
heißt die wollen eben
jenseits von kommunismus und
kapitalismus einen dritten weg
einschlagen denen sie sehr stark am
nationalsozialismus orientieren so ist
also die vorstellung dieser partei die
ungefähr 300 mitglieder umfasst der
junge mann ist zweimal strafrechtlich
verurteilt worden und zwar einmal wegen
betrugs und einmal wegen verstoßes gegen
das bayerische versammlungsgesetz er ist
beim dritten weg politisch aktiv hatte
vorher auch schon in anderen
rechtsextremen
kameradschaften und sich blicken lassen
also er bestand 20 20 die erste
juristische staatsprüfung in bayern und
wollte zunächst auch dort referendaren
hat sich also beworben aber seine
bewerbung wurde abgelehnt er klagte
dagegen so ungefähr in allen gerichten
wo es möglich ist also am
verwaltungsgericht bayerischer
verwaltungsgerichtshof und sogar im
bundesverfassungsgericht gibt aber
erfolglos und ging dann nach thüringen
um dort referendar zu werden auch das
klappte nicht und schließlich landete er
in sachsen bewarb sich dort und auch
dort lehnte dann
dort das oberlandesgericht aus
irgendwelchen gründen zuständig nicht
das verwaltungsgericht und lehnte dort
aber auch die lehnten ihn auch ab und
auch seine rechtsmittel blieben zunächst
jedenfalls
erfolglos die rechtslage in sachsen ist
jetzt ganz interessant da gibt es eine
neue vorschrift im sächsischen juristen
aus bildungsgesetz nämlich der paragraf
8 absatz 3 in dem es drei gründe gibt
warum jemand als referendar ab gelernt
abgelehnt werden kann also erst muss man
vielleicht einmal kurz sagen sachsen
wollte mit dieser neu eingeführten norm
das war ja ist und 20 21 sie glaube ich
erst in kraft getreten seine regeln
strenger machen nur um seine justiz
sozusagen besser zu schützen vor
verfassungsfeinden in den eigenen reihen
und aufgrund dieser norm ist jetzt aber
trotzdem dass sechs der sächsische
verfassungsgerichtshof zu dem ergebnis
gekommen dass es gerade nicht möglich
ist den bewerber abzulehnen das ist
schon so ein bisschen schräg ist ein
bisschen schräg vielleicht noch ganz
kurz um das in den politischen kontext
zuordnet beschäftigen sich ja
verfassungsschutzbehörden seit längerer
zeit mit diesen lagebild von
rechtsextremisten im öffentlichen dienst
und die politik hat das problem erkannt
dass ist dass es schwierig ist wenn
diejenigen die in diesem land verrechnen
ordnung sorgen sollen die gesetze
durchsetzen sollen usw selber
extremisten sind ja das funktioniert
natürlich dann nicht und insofern hat
man sich bemüht was aber sehr schwierig
ist das können wir bei anderer
gelegenheit nochmal besprechen warum das
ein schwieriges herauszufinden wer
eigentlich wo sitzt und in diesem zuge
haben dann auch länder angefangen zu
sagen na ja dann knüpfen wir doch
vielleicht mal früher an also nicht erst
bei der verbeamtung prüfen wir die
verfassungstreue sondern wenn wir die
verfassungsfeinde sage ich mal oder ich
jedenfalls die die keine verfassungs
freunde sind schon frühe aussortieren
nämlich beim referendariat dann kommen
sie ja gar nicht erst soweit sie spät am
höheren dienst irgendwo anfangen können
so die idee aber nicht alles das gut
gemeint ist wir wissen genau
[Musik]
jedenfalls ich sag kurz was in dieser
norm nun drin steht weil das wichtig ist
zum verständnis also in paragraf 8
absatz 3 sind eben drei gründe warum ein
bewerber vom vorbereitungsdienst
ausgeschlossen werden kann und zwar
erstens wenn eine vor wegen einer
vorsätzlich begangenen tat zu einer
freiheitsstrafe von mindestens einem
jahr rechtskräftig verurteilt wurde oder
wenn ein vermittlungs wenn ein
ermittlungsverfahren wegen einer solchen
vorsätzlich begangenen tat anhängig ist
die zu einer entscheidung führen kann
die ein jahr freiheitsstrafe mindestens
vorsieht also quasi wenn noch ein
verfahren läuft wo man davon ausgeht
dass könnte genau so ein ergebnis haben
bund jetzt für uns relevant ist aber der
die nummer drei nämlich hier heißt es
wenn die bewerberin oder der bewerber
die freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung in strafbarer weise
bekämpft so nämlich offenbar ist es so
dass die der der mann zwar zweimal
verurteilt wurde
aber eben nicht zu einer freiheitsstrafe
von mindestens einem jahr sonst wäre ja
genau das was der vereins heraus und
wenn dann für den verfassungsgerichtshof
die freiheit die strafbare bekämpfung
der freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung übrig zur prüfung genau und
jetzt ist die frage ist das passiert
oder nicht und da
sagt jetzt der sächsische
verfassungsgerichtshof nein unter diese
norm fällt das verhalten dieses jungen
mannes nicht und sie haben also gesagt
besitzer zur juristenausbildung also zum
referendariat zugelassen werden darf
nicht ausgeschlossen werden wird dann
sogar mit rückwirkend zum ersten
november
eingestellt da hat seinen dienst wurde
auch schon angetreten und hat den dienst
jetzt auch angetreten genau und die
sagen halt naja was heißt eigentlich die
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
in strafbarer weise bekämpfen heißt das
mitglied einer partei zu sein die zwar
als deutlich rechtsextrem eingestuft
wird aber eben nicht verboten ist und
was heißt dann in strafbarer weise
bekämpfen also man zwei straftaten
begangen hat das eine ist
versammlungsgesetz das andere ist betrug
das ist jedenfalls nicht ganz klar dass
das einen direkten bezug dazu hat das
ist schon mal das eine und dann sagt
dass das gericht aber man müsste diese
normen wahrscheinlich auch im lichte von
artikel 12 grundgesetz der
berufsfreiheit
sehr restriktiv auslegen und sagt macht
folgende gleichung auf die auch
einleuchtet dass er sagt nachher es kann
ja nicht sein dass wenn man mit
demselben verhalten anwalt werden kann
ja also nicht vom anwaltsberuf
ausgeschlossen wird sondern als anwalt
zugelassen würde dann kann es ja nicht
sein dass man dann kein referendariat
macht also also ja auch total an dass
die aufnahme den vorbereitungsdienst
dürfen nicht höher sein als die für die
zulassung zur rechtsanwaltschaft genau
das was irgendwann seine idee nicht alle
referendare werden arbeiten später in im
öffentlichen dienst in den
sicherheitsbehörden sondern werden
natürlich auch anwälte und insofern ist
das natürlich eine ja wenn man so will
liberale entscheidung die ein wenn man
sich wie ich mit dieser rechtsextremen
szene beschäftigt wie soll ich sagen da
schlagen zwei herzen in meiner brust
einerseits denke ich ja als wenn man das
ernst meint mit der rechtsstaatlichkeit
dann kommt man natürlich auch zu solchen
entscheidungen das ist klar damit müssen
wir dann leben und umgehen andererseits
ist es natürlich wirklich die frage was
tut man eigentlich dagegen dass der
staat und die behörden irgendwie
zunehmend unterwandert werden von leuten
die dann eben auch sehr spitzfindig sind
und wie dieser typ einfach in drei
ländern klagt und dann irgendwie aber
den unter absatz 5 findet und sagte ich
habe aber doch ein anspruch das ist
schon nicht ganz einfach allerdings noch
vielleicht zur ergänzung hat dann das
gericht noch gesagt na ja so ganz
hilflos seid ihr ja nicht gegen den
sondern ihr könnt ja
bestimmte anordnung treffen ja also zum
beispiel dass er zum beispiel keine
sitzungs vertretung bei der
staatsanwaltschaft machen darf oder
anderes die auflage keine
verfassungsfeindlichen symbole zu tragen
wobei ich da hin denken würde dass das
sowieso schon verboten ist und andere
dinge wie siehst du es denn also ich
sehe es genauso wie du da schlagen zwei
herzen in meiner brust ich halte diese
entscheidung aber oft der grundlage
dieser norm für fast die einzig richtige
also weil diese norm ist was man
vielleicht noch mal kurz sagen muss
einer norm in der
bundesrechtsanwaltsordnung nachgebildet
und deswegen hat das gericht finde ich
auch völlig zu recht gesagt wir können
nicht irgendwie jemanden der damit
anwalt werden dürfte nach dieser norm
wenn man sie eben vernünftig ausliegt
den können wir nicht schon verbieten
referendar zu werden denn man muss sich
ja schon mal klar machen dass man nicht
auf irgendeinem anderen weg volljurist
werden kann sondern der staat hat dann
ein ausbildungs monopol für alle
juristischen beruf und man muss halt
wenn man wenn jemand anwalt werden darf
muss man ihm meines erachtens zuvor
ermöglichen dass er sein referendariat
abschließen kann unter denselben
bedingungen da kann man in der tat nicht
strenger sein als nachher für die
anwaltszulassung dass man so jemanden
nicht im justizwesen haben möchte ich
glaube da sind wir uns total einig denn
das sind halt dann die fassung
verfassungsfeinde in den eigenen reihen
das kann brandgefährlich sein aber ich
glaube da muss man sich ehrlich gesagt
wenn man solche normen einführt vorher
überlegen ob man sich damit nicht ein
eigentor denn noch mal diese norm sollte
ja eigentlich ist die strengste norm
bundesweit soweit ich das weiß in
sachsen mit denen die sachsen anhalt
ihrem ihren justizdienst besonders gut
schützen wollten und jetzt am ende muss
man halt sagen na ja dann ist die norm
vielleicht einfach so eng dass dieser
schutz echt ein bisschen nach hinten
losgegangen ist denn in den anderen
ländern scheint es ja funktioniert zu
haben die haben ihn ja alle abgelehnt
und die haben halt offenere klauseln
also da gibt es dann
keine ahnung störung der öffentlichen
ordnung oder so was die natürlich mehr
möglich macht genau also werden wir die
gefahr für den geordneten ablauf oder
wichtige öffentliche belange darstellt
wo dann alles drunter fallen kann wo man
ehrlich gesagt auch unter
berücksichtigung von artikel 12 meines
erachtens das eng auslegen müsste und
jetzt nicht einfach nur jemand der weiß
nicht was ja also den geordneten ablauf
einmal gestört hat in irgend was auch
immer man sich da vorstellen kann
natürlich auch nicht sein also da aber
wir haben es gesehen die die gerichte in
thüringen und bayern haben einfach einen
haken hinter gemacht haben gesagt nein
den wollen wir nicht der ist hier gegen
unsere öffentlichen belange
verstößt die einstellung von ihm und
deswegen zack war die sache vorbei
insofern haben sich die sachsen da
tatsächlich ein bisschen ihr eigenes
kann man das in diesem zusammenhang
sagen da abgespielt tja oder vielleicht
das eigentor nehmen wir das eigentlich
vorgeschlagen
also das ist dann am ende halt schon
ärgerlich die wollten sich sozusagen
besser schützen machen die norm strenger
und weil sie dann am ende irgendwie zu
eng ist kriegen sie den dann nicht mehr
drunter also das ist dann echt nach
hinten losgegangen ich bin mal sehr
gespannt ob die anderen länder da
möglicherweise das darauf reagieren
werden denn also was man aus den ländern
so hört die schauen sich das schon an
wie das in sachsen abläuft nur die denn
das problem ist bekannt wie du gesagt
hast hier denen das nimmt auch zu und
die anderen länder haben eben schon
gesagt wir ziehen das ist da jetzt
erstmal nicht nach sondern schauen erst
mal was die sachsen damit machen naja
dieses erste urteil was jetzt auf dieser
grundlage ergeht ist erst mal macht noch
nicht so viel hoffnung dass das jetzt
sozusagen dieses gesetz diese neue norm
ihren zweck erfüllen kann naja also
interessanterweise übrigens habe ich
kürzlich gehört dass ich ein ich hatte
einen fall in meiner eigenen ag von
jemandem der ein problem mit dem
rechtsextremismus hatte und auch dann in
seiner späteren berufslaufbahn immer mal
wieder von bestimmten dingen
ausgeschlossen worden war
was wir alle ehrlich gesagt damals
überhaupt nicht wussten dass es so ist
ich habe das später erfahren der name
ist auch hin und wieder tauchte in den
medien auf und mein damaliger ag-leiter
im zivilrecht ist jetzt auch ein
fdp-politiker in berlin und da gab es
jetzt im april erstattung darüber ob er
weiterhin ags leiten darf weil er nun
hier ich bin gar nicht sicher aber jetzt
im abgeordnetenhaus jetzt jedenfalls
kandidiert und ja deutlich seine
position macht und also man merkt
nicht ist jetzt schon eine weile zurück
aber schon damals war es ein problem und
das wird größer
lassen wir dieses thema meint uns dass
wir natürlich weiter beobachten werden
und kommen jetzt zu dem schönen thema
was ich den eindruck habe es beschäftigt
uns alle und vor allem die anwaltschaft
und vor allem auf die
bundesrechtsanwaltskammer doch schon
sehr sehr lange und immer mal wieder
ging doch vieles schief oder ja also das
bea ist das besondere elektronische
anwalts postfach für alle nicht
juristinnen und juristen die uns hier zu
hören und es ist also das bea ist nur
eines der themen das sich jetzt zum
ersten ersten 20 22 ändert ich habe es
schon im intro angesprochen dass
deutsche rechtswesen wird digital es ist
unfassbar allerdings wollen wir
natürlich über den schwerpunkt bea
sprechen weil tatsächlich das bea von
anfang an wie soll man sagen ein
bisschen eine geschichte voller
missverständnisse war komme ich gleich
noch mal drauf ich fange mal damit an
was ich jetzt eigentlich ändert ab dem
11 müssen anwältinnen und anwälte
behörden und juristische personen des
öffentlichen rechts achtung achtung
achtung elektronisch mit den gerichten
kommunizieren ich fasse es nicht ja es
ist unglaublich genau also theoretisch
könnte man das natürlich auch auf
anderem sichere übermittlung sweg machen
jetzt gerade als anmelden oder anwalt
man könnte also eine de mail verschicken
jeder weiß kein mensch verschickte e
mails am ende läuft ist also darauf
hinaus dass das jetzt die sogenannte
aktive nutzungspflicht ist für das
besondere elektronische anwalts postfach
pa für die anwälte jetzt komme ich zu
dem was du gesagt hast lange geschichte
schon seit 2008 zehn müssen alle
anwältinnen und anwälte das postfach
passiv nutzen wenn man dass das heißt
man muss post die in bahrain geht gegen
sich gelten lassen also wenn ich jetzt
als anwältin post bekommen da ist eine
frist drin und ich verkenne die dann bin
ich halt auf jeden fall schuld wenn ich
einfach keinen bh zugang hatte und das
ding nicht abgerufen habe das gilt schon
seit 2008 10 trotzdem muss man sagen
dass die begeisterung auf seiten der
anwaltschaft sich doch ziemlich in
grenzen hielt und das lag auch daran
dass schon diese passive nutzungspflicht
eigentlich schon anfang 2018 kommen
sollte aber verschoben werden musste
wegen massiver technischer probleme also
eigentlich sollte das bier schon 216
online gehen da wurde es zu 17 dann
wurde es endlich online geschaltet und
nur wenige wochen nachdem es online
gegangen war musste die
bundesrechtsanwaltskammer die ist
verantwortlich für die umsetzung und den
betrieb des br das ganze ding und zwar
an weihnachten ich weiß es noch weil ich
dann arbeiten musste das war wirklich
sehr unerfreulich ich saß am zweiten
weihnachtsfeiertag am schreibtisch weil
das bier vom netz genommen wurde weil es
massive sicherheitslücken damals gab das
ganze lief also wirklich super ruckelig
an das bier war sehr schnell sehr
verschrien es gab dann auch in den
gesamten ersten monaten fast schon
jahren muss man sagen echt viele
ausfälle und downtimes aber es ist so
ein bisschen in ruhigeres fahrwasser
geraten in den letzten ein zwei jahren
würde ich sagen wahrscheinlich auch weil
es ein dienstleister wechsel gegeben hat
also ein wechsel des technischen
dienstleisters das ist gewechselt vom
vom dienstleister atos zum dienstleister
des rock und auch so etwas was ich so
aus der anwaltschaft höre das ist nicht
nur seit dem stabiler sondern das ganze
system ist halt auch wesentlich besser
betreut also auch der services viel viel
besser da gibt es halt auch hotlines und
so wo man anrufen kann als verwirrter
anwalt wenn man mal wieder nicht klar
kommt sowas würde natürlich mir nie
passieren als ich aus technischen
gründen mit irgendwas nicht klarkomme
apropos technische gründe von dieser
aktuellen ich hoffe ich sage das jetzt
richtig lok vor jay sicherheitslücke die
jetzt eben das letzte wochenende ich
glaube alle it dieses landes sehr
beschäftigt hat und die auch in bio
komponenten verwendet wurde war das bier
zwar theoretisch betroffen weil eben
auch diese diese komponente sich darin
findet aber die brack und west rock
haben das bier kurzfristig vom netz
genommen und die schutzlücke nach
eigenen angaben nach dem was die
pressesprecherin der bracke mir gesagt
hat schon am samstag wieder geschlossen
es gab allerdings kleiner hinweis dann
eine neue version die man darauf spielen
muss die muss man jetzt zwingend auf
spielen sonst hat man keinen zugriff auf
das bea ich habe es ehrlich gesagt seit
dem wochenende noch nicht getestet soll
aber automatisch funktionieren so jetzt
haben wir also seit jahren diese passive
nutzungspflicht und wie gesagt die
begeisterung der anwaltschaft hielt sich
sehr in grenzen
jetzt sind wir aber alle dran gab dem
ersten müssen anwältinnen und anwälte
und das heißt auch alle zugelassenen
syndikus anwälte also die juristinnen
und juristen in den unternehmen das bea
wirklich benutzen wenn sie dokumente an
ein gericht schicken wollen das muss man
sich klar machen das ist ein komplett
neuer weg das ist quasi um es in den
worten der fdp zu sagen digital first es
ist crazy es steht jetzt im gesetz
dokumente sind elektronisch an die
gerichte zu schicken das ist es auch gar
nicht mehr in briefumschlag tun oder
ok dann hast du denn schon pia fangen
wir doch mal so an du bist doch
zugelassene rechtsanwälte hast du denn
schon dein bier selbst
verlassen
nein und ich würde auch dringend nicht
empfehlen das erst an weihnachten machen
denn man muss das dauert schon so ein
bisschen bis man die kiste installiert
kriegt und trotzdem gibt es aber ich
habe es tatsächlich bei der brak bei der
bundesrechtsanwaltskammer noch mal
nachgefragt es gibt stand 30 da immer
noch rund zehn prozent der
niedergelassenen an werte und und
achtung rund 30 prozent der
syndikusanwalt
hier heißt es denn auch schon mal
ausprobiert ob es auch funktioniert
natürlich also ich meine dass ich habe
das wäre jetzt tatsächlich schon seit
jahren in benutzung und es ist jetzt so
wie formuliere ich das jetzt freundlich
wenn man an die benutzeroberflächen von
google und apple gewöhnt ist ist es
nicht so dass man sagt gp total
benutzerfreundlich das erschließt sich
mir alles sofort also man muss sich
damit schon so ein bisschen irgendwie
auseinandersetzen aber und das jetzt
echt mal ernst gemeint weil sind
syndikus anwältin werden kann ich das
noch verstehen weil die haben ja in den
unternehmen in aller regel kaum kontakt
zu gerichten das heißt sie haben ja
externe anwälte die die beschäftigen und
die haben den kontakt zu gerichten also
da habe ich noch ein gewisses
verständnis dafür dass da ist immer noch
irgendwie 30 prozent der suizid ist
nicht geschafft haben sich beim b
anzumelden aber zehn prozent der
niedergelassenen anwältin anwälte das
ist schon echt noch krass fiel selbst
wenn man sagt da gibt es eine menge
wohnzimmer kanzleien die eigentlich
nicht wirklich anwaltlich tätig sind
oder so das ist echt viel und jetzt hast
du denn mal nach der alterstruktur
zufällig gefragt oder haben die daher
darüber daten erhoben also es gibt keine
daten dazu ich vermute auch dass es auch
damit zu tun haben dürfte dass
wahrscheinlich einige die vielleicht
auch noch eine anwaltszulassung haben
aber gar nicht mehr so tätig sind weil
sie eigentlich schon in rente sind denn
auch rente darf man seine zulassung ja
noch behalten dass die dann vermutlich
einfach keine lust haben sich mit dieser
neuen mit dieser ganzen neuen technik
jedoch so
man könnte natürlich auch sagen ja das
system geht ja sowieso ständig in die
glieder deswegen muss ich mich jetzt
irgendwie damit nicht rum stressen diese
befürchtung gab es auch total massiv
wenn es jetzt also vorgeschrieben ist
dass die gesamte kommunikation mit den
gerichten auf elektronischem wege
stattfinden muss schaffen dass die
server auch das habe ich bei der bracke
fragt die praxis nach eigenen angaben
wir sind gut gerüstet da für sie gehen
aber davon aus dass das volumen der
versendeten sich nachrichten sich
achtung fast verachtfachen wird also
meant gibt es monatlich rund vier
millionen nachrichten die versendet und
empfangen werden laut auskunft der bank
und die bank geht davon aus dass es
künftig bis zu 27 millionen nachrichten
pro monat sind und da wird auch mal in
einer der nächsten folgen im neuen jahr
würde ich sagen wir ab mal nachfragen
was findest du dir wünschen uns
natürlich allen anwältinnen und anwälten
ergebnis aber schon auch echte
unsicherheiten also weil die bank eben
auch selber sagt dass sie nicht wissen
wie viel die gerichte ihrerseits dann
elektronisch kommunizieren werden die
praxis wir gehen nicht davon aus dass ab
dem ersten ersten 20 22 alle gerichte
auf die elektronische versendung
umstellen werden denn das ist der witz
an welchen anwälte und behörden müssen
jetzt elektronisch kommunizieren
gerichte müssen das noch nicht die
justiz ist das sind die eigentlich oder
dass man sich 26 26 da ist natürlich
irgendwie noch eine weile hin und da
gibt es halt bei den fachgerichten die
sind jetzt echt schon weit also
arbeitsgerichte verwaltungsgericht
sozialgerichte und so die sich schon
richtig weit also da kann man glaube ich
schon sagen dass die fast bundesweit
schon fast flächendeckend elektronisch
versenden aber in der ordentlichen
gerichtsbarkeit also im zivil und
strafrecht muss man wirklich sagen da
gibt es gerichte die sind noch komplett
hinter moan die sind praktisch noch
nicht an die elektronische kommunikation
angeschlossen und ich glaube man kann
auch schon davon ausgehen dass das noch
ziemlich lange dauern wird ich habe
gestern noch mit martin hof gesprochen
geschäftsführer der anwaltskammer hier
in köln ganz liebe grüße gehen raus ein
fettes shoutout an martin der hat mir
zum beispiel erzählt dass er nochmal
beim nrw justizministerium nachgefragt
hat und die haben gegenüber den
geschäftsführern der anwaltskammer
nonchalant erklärt dass die justiz in
nrw darauf vorbereitet sei die neuen
mengen an elektronischer kommunikation
zu empfangen und zu verbreiten ich bin
mal gespannt ob das dann auch
tatsächlich so in allen an allen
gerichten gerade in der ordentlichen
gerichtsbarkeit
funktionieren wird aber bitte bitte
leute gestattet mit den aufruf noch
schaut euch dieses beran es hilft ja nix
ihr müsst jetzt ab dem 11 es gibt auf
dem support portal der brecht auch ganz
gute anleitungen und so ein aktuelles
zehn-punkte-papier das können wir euch
auch noch in die chance packen wirklich
so bh für anfänger das ist echt ganz
nett gemacht das versteht man super gut
und das ganze dauert auch ein bisschen
man braucht nämlich eine karte die muss
man bei der bundesnotarkammer bestellen
und ein lesegerät und so das heißt wenn
man jetzt noch gar nichts gemacht hat
dann ist man eh schon recht wichtig spät
dran für den ersten ersten und man muss
sich das schon auch ein bisschen
angucken vielleicht ja auch integrieren
in die in die kanzlei software und so
und auch da noch mal den den aufruf vom
berufs rechtler von martin hof dem
geschäftsführer der anwaltskammer köln
der halt sagt es ist halt auch nicht nur
eine nutzungspflicht sondern es ist auch
einfach total sinnvoll über das bier zu
korrespondieren und zwar auch
untereinander mit anderen anwältinnen
und anwälten denn dann hat man keine
datenschutz themen das steht halt im
gesetz über das bea darfst du alles
versenden denn das ist ein sich der
übermittlung sweg dann hast du halt kein
thema mehr mit irgendwas genau dass da
gab es ja am anfang glaube ich auch die
frage wie sicher ist dass datenschutz
und so weiter sind ja dass diese daten
aber das ist ja alles bereit wurden auch
da wurde auch geklagt und so und alle
die gesamte justiz hat sich hinter das
bea gestellt also da gab es dann auch
klagen wo man gesagt hat das ist nicht
ende-zu-ende verschlüsselt und so ja
also kein grund zur sorge und ich will
noch in kleinen mutmacher anfügen weil
wir ja auch zwei neue redaktionssysteme
und anderes hier kriegen und auch ganz
natürlich immer
diesem online schulungen und das ist
alles immer auch kein großer jubel der
dann ausbricht aber wenn man einmal
geschafft hat dann gewöhnt man sich doch
immer ganz schnell doch wieder anders
neu und stellt fest dass es meistens
dann auch vieles noch besser
funktioniert und so weiter deswegen wir
schaffen das doch irgendwie
wenn wir uns doch auch irgendwie
digitalisieren wollen also ist es ja
auch immer noch man ist ja international
wenn man die deutsche justiz guckt ist
es ja doch immer so ein bisschen
peinlich wie dann immer die richter noch
wie diese ganzen gürteltiere da also
diese riesen akten kirchen schleppen und
so weiter das alles immer noch
handschriftlich hier und da einen findet
man aber die seite nicht und so das
können sich ja teilweise
menschen die im ausland in der justiz
tätig sind gar nicht vorstellen das ist
bei uns noch so ist und von der suche
der richter das auch noch so toll finden
ja genau also deswegen denke ich auch
ich glaube kurz vor 2026 wird nicht die
komplette vor allem die die ordentliche
gerichtsbarkeit bestimmt nicht
digitalisiert sein weil da gibt es
einfach an der justiz auch wahnsinnig
viele vorbehalte nur das muss man echt
sagen aber es hilft nichts die anwälte
müssen jetzt ran also liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen da draußen hier trefft euch
endlich mal auf guckt euch das an und
denkt dran wenn dir das bea benutzt auch
dass noch ein freundlicher hinweis von
martin hof beim bh muss man genau
dieselben sorg verpflichten einheiten
wie wenn man übers fax verschickt also
man muss auch beim br immer gucken ob da
auch wirklich der empfang bestätigt
wurde und nicht nur der versand und so
und wenn man einmal über das bh was
versendet hat dann darf man nicht danach
aufhören es zu versenden also schaut
euch an guckt euch ein bisschen die
berufsrechtlichen an es hilft nichts ab
dem 11 es macht auch sinn und einer
anwältin sagte neulich zu mir das fand
ich auch total süß ich brauche fast gar
keine briefmarken mehr was ich da spare
sie haben die klicks ich denke habe ich
noch nie drüber frage dabei ist richtig
also wer kommt das deutsche justizwesen
koste drittel macht mit
sophia und jetzt sind ja auch schon beim
gerechten urteil was sehr lebensnahe ist
jedenfalls an deinem und teilweise auch
an meinem oder
also das klingt immer ein bisschen
lustig die sogenannten wegeunfälle das
klingt immer etwas lustig es geht darum
ob unfälle auf dem weg zur arbeit
versichert sind ja nein vielleicht und
da hat das bundessozialgericht in der
vergangenen woche entschieden dass ein
sturz auf dem weg vom achtung
schlafzimmer ins arbeitszimmer im home
office ein arbeitsunfall ist das heißt
dass die berufsgenossenschaft dafür
bezahlt muss ich sag es mit absicht man
muss einmal so ein bisschen grinsen weil
das eigentlich nach lustigen fällen
klingt am ernstfall ist das überhaupt
nicht lustig in diesem fall war es auch
nicht lustig da hat sich ein
gebietsverkaufsleiter zwar schon im jahr
2018 für relativ schwer verletzt also
der ist von seiner frau darum wichtig
aufgefunden worden und war dann an der
wirbelsäule verletzt weil er morgens
aufgestanden ist und dann auf dem weg
zur arbeit in seinem häuslichen
arbeitszimmer auf der wendeltreppe
ausgerutscht ist
er hat dann dazu vorgetragen vor gericht
auch das klingt lustig ist es aber gar
nicht er würde ja in der regel nie
frühstücken kann immer aufstehen und
dann direkt arbeiten gehen klingt so ein
bisschen absurd
es geht aber bei der frage ob ein unfall
auf dem betriebsweg sondern man das
passiert immer darum ob der versicherte
gerade eine tätigkeit ausüben wollte die
dem unternehmen dient das waren halt
bisher dann immer so fälle wo dann die
berufsgenossenschaften sagen moment mal
also wenn du erst morgens mal noch 100
meter rechts rumpf erst um morgens zum
bäcker zu fahren und dir ein brötchen
holt zu holen auf dem weg zur arbeit
dann war das aber nicht ein weg zur
arbeit und dann ist da ein unfall nicht
versichert also das ist immer schon so
ein bisschen amok und da gibt es
tatsächlich also hunderte von fällen die
echt ein bisschen absurd anmutet und
wenn man dann davon spricht dass man
sich nur noch an der eigenen wohnung
bewegt wird es natürlich noch so ein
bisschen lustiger also der typ durfte
hier und haben natürlich auch nicht
vorgetragen ich wollte frühstücken gehen
im unteren stockwerk sondern natürlich
hat er gesagt ich wollte zum
arbeitszimmer zum arbeiten gehen und da
hat jetzt das bundessozialgericht gesagt
jo da gelten dieselben maßstäbe die
haben gesagt ein betriebsweg ist
ausnahmsweise auch im häuslichen bereich
denkbar wenn sich wohnung und
arbeitsstätte im selben gebäude befinden
haben sich dabei selbst zitiert das ist
ein urteil das stand schon aus dem jahr
2016 und ob ein weg als betriebsweg
sozusagen definiert wird im
unmittelbaren unternehmensinteresse
stattfindet also bestimmt sich auch im
home office nach der objektivierten
handlungs tendenz des versicherten also
auf deutsch gesagt danach ob der gerade
etwas beruflich motiviertes machen
wollten das ist ein sehr sinnvolles
urteil zumal es eben zur alten
rechtslage entschieden wurde das ist ein
bisschen merkwürdig weil in dem in dem
pressebericht zumindest vom bundestages
die machen immer nur so termins berichte
keine richtigen pressemitteilung findet
sich überhaupt nichts darin dass es seit
juni 20 21 neue regelung gibt im
sozialgesetzbuch 7 steht nämlich jetzt
dass wenn die versicherte tätigkeit im
haushalt des versicherten oder an einem
anderen ort ausgeübt wird der
versicherungsschutz genauso besteht wie
bei wie wenn man im büro arbeitet also
der weg zur arbeit ist da jetzt immer
noch nicht explizit geregelt aber man
muss natürlich schon sagen wenn jetzt
diese norm in kraft ist dann müssen
genau dieselben regeln gelten das ist so
ein bisschen merkwürdig dass das
bundessozialgericht überhaupt nichts
dazu gesagt hat das ist schon geändert
wurde aber vielleicht steht dazu in dem
urteil noch mehr auf jeden fall wir
finden das ist ein mega gerechtes urteil
das finde ich vor allem weil ich auch
eine wendeltreppe habe und ich es
durchaus mir gut vorstellen könnte mich
der halsbrecherisch auf socken morgens
auf dem weg in mein arbeitszimmer hatte
auch vorher im frühstücks bevor du dich
an die arbeit machen oder nein doch ich
frühstücke ich würde das aber natürlich
auch anders sagen so jetzt
und sofort zurück nein natürlich aber
nur ist es tatsächlich so mein
arbeitszimmer ist auch im unteren
stockwerk im schlafzimmer ist im oberen
stockwerk das heißt wenn ich dann fertig
gemacht und gefrühstückt runter kommen
könnte ich mich da durchaus hinlegen
bevor ich mehr als ein ziel wenn man so
ist nein und insgesamt ist es ja so dass
wir alle wissen vor der pandemie immer
so getan werde als seine office mehr
oder weniger würde man da eigentlich
nichts tun außer wäsche zusammenlegen
geschirrspüler ausräumen und die blumen
gießen und ansonsten das ein oder andere
telefonat
beantworten spätestens seit der pandemie
wissen wir ja dass das wirklich nicht
stimmt dass man im home-office sehr
viele arbeitet sogar mehr als im büro
weil man kaum mit kollegen spricht es
sei denn natürlich am telefon und weil
man auch ansonsten
durch im grunde nichts abgelenkt wird
sondern die ganze zeit am rödeln ist und
da kann es dann eigentlich keine mehr
sein und immer noch mehr weil man guckt
mal zum arbeiten kommt darauf an was man
für kollegen hat noch
würde ich sagen dass es das dass es
nicht sein kann dass der schutz werk und
wir sind ja nicht freiwillig im home
office ist muss man ja auch mal sagen
wir sind ja im home office als
gemeinschaftliche anstrengung das ist
auch nicht immer schön also ich kann es
jedenfalls für mich sagen am anfang
hatte ich das ja ganz attraktiv und
irgendwann ging es mir dann wahnsinnig
auf die nerven und ich habe mich immer
gefreut wenn ich mal ins büro konnte und
da kann es ja nicht sein dass der schutz
dann geringer ist wenn man dort einen
unfall hat auch wenn wir natürlich alle
hoffen auch pia wenn du auf socken
runter geht es vielleicht wünschte der
mann paar weiß ich so ist aus schuhe die
hausschuhe oder so wenn schon gewonnen
socken oder
gut also wenn ansonsten werden sie
lieben hörerinnen und hörer ihrerseits
vorschläge für weihnachtsgeschenke für
pia haben oder ansonsten
noch
lob oder kritik
alles herzlich willkommen an
themenvorschlägen und sonstigen
stellungnahmen aller art freuen wir uns
sehr unter der bekannten adresse die ich
aber noch mal sagen nämlich einspruch
podcast faz.de
in der kommenden woche bist du wieder
dabei zusammen mit corinna und ihr
machen dann eine jahre am schluss folge
gab das wird eine ganz besondere folge
kündige ich schon mal an freut euch
drauf und der rest ist ein geheimnis und
wir hören uns wieder im kommenden jahr
worauf ich mich jetzt schon sehr freue
alles gute und
vor allem bleibt und bleiben sie gesund
hieß es war mir wie immer eine freude
bleibt uns gewogen georgia eine gute
woche da draußen
[Musik]